bonsoir Oui bonsoir alors les cops se
succèdent depuis 1995 c'est conférences
là sans vraiment réussir si on regarde
les faits à faire diminuer les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ce que ça sert
encore à quelque chose de faire ces
conférences
vous êtes pas la première nous poser la
question je pense que cette copie nous
reflète l'urgence d'agir je pense qu'il
faut avoir à l'esprit c'est que s'il n'y
avait pas eu ces moments-là c'est comme
plat donné année après année les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
auraient augmenté encore plus donc oui
les émissions ont grandement augmenté
les engagements ne tiennent pas toujours
la route c'est beaucoup ce qu'on
reproche mais les codes sont un moment
extrêmement important parce que
annuellement les États se rencontrent
pour discuter de qu'est-ce qu'ils
doivent faire la pression elle est mise
autant à l'international qu'au sein des
États pour que les États rendent compte
donc pas simplement qu'il fasse des
belles promesses mais aussi qu'il puisse
respecter ces engagements là au Canada
au Québec ce que ça fait c'est que ça
fait que des populations des sociétés
civile des entreprises des organisations
qui demandent davantage de transparence
davantage d'action et s'il n'y avait pas
ces moments-là mais chaque année on
perdrait une occasion d'en parler parce
que on l'a vu en début de présentation
les émissions augmentent il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose au plus
vite et là on fait quoi durant cette cop
c'est quoi l'objectif de cette rencontre
si cette année
plusieurs objectifs
jamais on se rend compte
est-ce que ce mécanisme là des pertes et
dommages dont vous avez parlé et
distincts des 100 milliards de dollars
prévus que les pays du Nord se sont
engagés à verser au pays du Sud
oui ça serait la création idéalement
d'un fond distinct pour qu'on puisse
faire face de manière momentanée à des
conséquences des changements climatiques
par exemple des inondations qui ont lieu
au Pakistan les Pakistanais ne sont pas
responsables dans l'entièreté des
impacts qui sont associés à ça donc
comment on fait pour aider ces pays-là à
se relever pour ne pas qu'ils vivent des
inéquités rattachées aux impacts des
changements climatiques comment on a des
régions qui vivent des certifications à
devoir à déplacer des populations par
exemple déplacer des routes et c'est ça
un peu la logique des pertes préjudices
c'est qu'au-delà de l'adaptation et
au-delà de l'atténuation il y a des gens
qui ici maintenant vivent des impacts
des changements climatiques et on doit
compenser les pertes et les dommages que
ces gens le vivent et c'est ça un des
nœuds de discussion qui aura lieu cette
année à Charles échec compenser par les
pays riches mais un pays comme la Chine
ont fait quoi c'est le premier émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre du monde qui dit
nous sommes nous un pays en voie de
développement qu'est-ce qu'on fait avec
la Chine
vous touchez là un enjeu extrêmement
important la position de la chaîne elle
est particulière parce que ils doivent
aussi trouver des moyens pour aider une
grosse partie de la population qui vit
encore sous le seuil de la pauvreté
aussi à se développer mais en même temps
on ne peut pas demander à la Chine qui
est le premier émetteur de gaz à effet
de serre de de recevoir aussi des fonds
publics alors qu'ils contribue de
manière extrêmement importante à la
problématique des changements
climatiques donc le rôle que la Chine
jouera va être très très particulier
sera surveillé pendant la prochaine Coop
je pense que ça il faut retenir cet
élément là mais il faut aussi voir et
penser au pays les plus vulnérables et
je pense que la notion des pertes et
dommages risque de s'orienter davantage
vers ces pays-là et c'est ce qu'on
souhaite c'est vraiment que pour les
populations les plus vulnérables qu'on
puisse les accompagner dans ce
processus-là il y a la guerre en Ukraine
qui se poursuit qui a mis en lumière la
grande insécurité énergétique finalement
de plusieurs pays l'Allemagne quelques
pays européens et les besoins les
besoins qui sont grandissant en gaz et
en pétrole on a l'impression les
énergies fossiles ont renaît en ce
moment est-ce que ces impératifs là
viennent compliquer vraiment la lutte
contre les changements climatiques
oui on peut on pourra pas se cacher que
ce qui se passe sur le plan énergétique
à cause de la 40e crée un problème
extrêmement important mais ce qu'il faut
voir c'est quand même temps notamment
les pays européens investissent comme
jamais dans les énergies de transition
donc c'est ça aussi qu'il faut voir que
si à court terme il y a des éléments
très problématiques au niveau des
hydrocarbures il faut continuer à miser
et tout miser sur les déploiements des
énergies renouvelables et tenter autant
que possible de réduire notre dépendance
aux hydrocarbures parce que on comprend
que cette dépendance là mène à une
insécurité extrêmement grande si ce
n'était pas de la guerre en Ukraine ceci
il y aurait quand même énormément
d'autres conséquences à y attribuer donc
oui c'est un enjeu à considérer et il
faut y faire face rapidement un échec
merci beaucoup c'était très clair et
intéressant merci d'avoir été avec nous
merci à vous au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI
[Musique]